uh why don't we check in with uh
oh i don't know maybe uh david from uh
the united kingdom
david from london you're on the air hi
can you hear me
i can hey um it's so great to talk to
you i've been following you for about a
year now pleasure um
i had a really dying question during
the uh election which i guess it was
more of a difference between how the uk
run their elections in the americans yes
and i found it so bizarre
the way uh results came out piecemeal
like bit by bit
because in the uk we kind of
announced the results when everything's
been counted right
and uh it just struck me as so bizarre
that
trump kept talking about massive dumps
and
went to bed and he was up and then he
was down i
really didn't understand why
the u.s system was like that and i just
yeah it was just a dying question i was
uh speaking with one of my american
friends about
thing and he didn't understand why
either and yeah i mean i don't i don't
have an
answer as to why other than to say
that it's been this way for a long time
i i'm
i don't know if you could even restrict
i mean listen you know
as we have 50 states and the states
collect results from the individual
counties and and municipalities
um i just don't know if you could even
could you even tell everybody do not
release any information
until i i just don't know it it is
though it is sort of strange
um it is like it would be
it would have it would have stopped this
whole kind of uh
angle of you know fox news saying oh and
11 p.m
you know it really wouldn't and here's
why it wouldn't prevent it here's the
problem david
imagine that there's a there's a
different system where
the numbers are announced when they are
final
when it's really close like it was in
georgia
if they said hey we have it's been eight
days
we now have the results then trump and
fox news and others would just say
eight days that's really suspicious i'm
sure they spent that time manipulating
the numbers so it actually wouldn't
solve the problem
i guess you're damned if you do damned
if you don't essentially
yes they're always going to have some
kind of opinion against why it's not
correct
absolutely um yeah i just wanted to say
again like
been following you for about a year and
i i honestly i come
home after work well i mean i'm mainly
working from home but
come back and i think around 8 9 p.m
your show kicks in i actually start your
live stream
have it in the background tab when the
music kicks in although lately the music
hasn't kicked in that much which i've
been a bit disappointed
we're doing more live stream music
lately we've got some good new good new
tracks we've been st
you know i could be watching something
else or eating dinner with my girlfriend
and i'm like right i'm sorry i have to
stop
well i appreciate it i appreciate it
what uh what part of london are you in
generally
so i live in catford which is a park
it's catford yeah which is um southeast
london
so i work in i work in peckham which you
may or may not know
uh south london again so this is all
this is all south of the river right
i'm south of the river yes understood i
did go to a pub
in a working uh uh sort of a a
blue i don't know what the right term is
working class blue collar i don't want
to say the wrong word
aries south of the river
with my cousin when i was in london and
it was quite an experience it was sort
of like a soccer pub i guess i would say
okay yeah fantastic well i mean if
you're
if you're next in london i don't know if
we can even travel between the us
and the uk right now i guess you can't
but if you're ever in london and wanted
to do a talk or anything like that i
would definitely be
wanting to come and watch you give a
lecture or something like that and i'm
trying to spread the word to my uh
colleagues and friends around about you
and how you
uh do these live streams and yeah i just
think it's really great
my friend actually he'd never seen
someone
i live tweet and live stream before as a
kind of way to like put out content
he found the whole thing kind of
fascinating and i've kind of got him
into watching younow and i send all the
links out to my friends when
when you come on it's really great well
thank you i i appreciate the support
from across the pond
all right thank you very much there is
david from london england
that is all the time i have today for
calls via discord
i'm sorry i wasn't able to get to
everybody but we will take
calls again